mr lynch great to have you on the
programme this morning um i wonder if
you could start by just by just
reminding our viewers the purposes of
these strikes what it would take
for you to step away from the pickets
well we've still got the issues at the
start the the companies network rail and
the train operators want to cut
thousands of jobs from our industry and
we think that will have an impact on
safety and obviously our members
future they want to rip up our
conditions of service
uh
the train operating companies is also
attacking our pensions
and of course we haven't had a pay deal
across much of the industry for two or
three years
so our members are feeling the effects
of the cost of living crisis but they're
also worried about their futures
we need to negotiate a settlement with
14 train operating companies and network
rail we're seeking to do that virtually
every day of the week
but i think the obstacle here at the
moment is the stance of the
the minister grant shaps
and backed up by the treasury and i
think that's got a bit uh wound up with
the conservative party leadership
uh process
so if we can get uh the companies
negotiating freely
without being shackled by the government
we can negotiate a settlement for this
dispute
and get the railways back to to running
fully
i mean
you'll you'll accept i i'm sure that it
is difficult for those of us who are not
sitting around the negotiating table to
judge what is being said by both sides
we're simply not in the room so when the
government say that that the rmt and on
behalf of their members have rejected an
eight percent pay rise that wouldn't
include compulsory redundancies i mean
is that true or not and and if it is
true why the rejection
so that is an offer for for network rail
and it's at half of this dispute on the
train operating companies we've haven't
had an offer at all but it also means
that we would have to accept massive
changes to our members working lives
that at this time are unpalatable and
unacceptable the offer is also over
three years it's not an eight percent
offer for this year we didn't get a pay
deal last year it's four percent this
year and four percent next year so it's
eight percent over three years inflation
yesterday came out the retail price
index at 12.3
there are predictions for next year that
it could be up to 15 percent
so we could what they're asking us to do
is accept the gamble that next year
our members might receive a quarter of
the rate of inflation
and of course this year when the deal
should have been struck
it was 7.1 so if you
if you add those together it could have
been well over 20 22
something in that region and they're
asking us to accept eight
yesterday there was a deal done on the
bus services in the north at 11.1
we've had a deal done in the aviation
industry of 12 and 13 this week so
they're not offering us anything really
they're offering a real term pay cut
just and a pay cut against the rate of
inflation at that time at this time
that's not acceptable to our people
sorry to interrupt there we're really
pushing for time i just want to kind of
drill down into this particular point
everyone is we saw cpi inflation at 10.1
percent yesterday the expectation is
that that will rise to 13 by the end of
the year who knows what it will do in
the first six months of of next year but
you could say as a likelihood it could
go could go even higher does that mean
that the rmt's negotiating positions is
directly linked to where inflation might
be in the future or where it is now i
mean if they were to offer you 10 this
morning would you take it
well they're not gonna offer me ten
percent this morning so that's a high
percentage
but you do get the point you you do get
the point that if we were to accept four
percent for this year and four percent
for next year our members would be
poorer as a result of that deal so the
reference point that we use is the
retail price index other people use the
consumer's price index what we've got to
do is get a package and it's not just
about pay it's about jobs if you haven't
got a job you're not going to get a pay
rise anyway it's about the people's
conditions of service where they want
them to work
more on social hours and we're already
working they want them to change
the way they work and on the train
operating companies which is the
majority of railway workers in this
country we haven't got a pay off at all
and we haven't had one for three years
at the same time they're threatening to
close every booking office in this
country and take all the guards off the
trains so grant shap said that at the
weekend that he wants a guardless
railway service we can't accept any of
that so we've got some real difficulties
to to to address and we will do that
to companies through negotiations
yeah apologies for interrupting we've
literally got two minutes left in the
program i do just want to try and
squeeze in another couple of questions i
mean in your mind how close are we to a
general strike
well only the cuc can call a general
strike what we're seeing across the
country i address the meeting thousands
of people last night are addressed a
massive one in glasgow
on tuesday there is a wave of reaction
amongst working people to the way
they're being treated people are getting
poorer every day of the week people
can't pay their bills they're getting
treated despicably in the workplace i
think there will be generalized and
synchronized action it may not be in the
traditional form but we've seen the the
post office workers and bt
we've seen the bus workers in london out
on strike tomorrow and over the weekend
i think there is a massive response
coming from working people because
they're fed up with the way they're
being treated it's starting to look at
look a little bit like a general site
look as things stand quite clearly i
think people understand you've got your
majority of public support on your side
and certainly the rmt and other unions
are suggesting that you can afford to
carry on striking for months do you
accept that with the way inflation is
going there will come a point where when
your house your members can afford you
going on strike
the rest of the country can't afford you
going on strike lower paid workers can't
afford to afford you going on strike
well nobody can afford to go on strike
they don't want to be on strike they
want a settlement but they are
completely
tied into this dispute i addressed the
meeting of thousands of our members last
night online and they are totally
committed to the campaign that we've got
they understood the issues when they
voted for it and they're showing on the
picket lines that they're completely
committed to the cause we will keep
going until we get a negotiated
settlement and our members will decide
whether it's acceptable or not lynch
we're just literally about to go into
the commercial break so thank you for
squeezing that answer then we'll speak
again